which spector and
to leave
the new gameplay of macristas what's
the construction to the coach the light videos
in fact it is
and they say
once again
the canitec
of honduras
with lidia in lanjarón
[Music]
usually big mails from the web
write up to 10 billion
uy
undecided  she's in peace she's tired of being questioned
and I
[Music]
in one
better
and stronger
and NATO
sanz planning and art from austin
this is the 5th
yes
ins that the must
ok
[Applause]
[Music]
what an experience
reuters
me  no
they were going jazz jazz
the truth
no
good
don't buy them
whether you're a hype
what was
as it is
compare
escairón and that
's maybe the dip
bombau
cause they were already
rich
[Music]
no no
and delivery
with your beds
masks
tumbes
go home
[Applause  ]
maxwell
good
cows
[Applause]
amen
bye bye
thanks
go
fatal
but
there is love
[Applause]
and he did it to me
to sing he's
not going to think
now of course
I'll go
cuicateca
[Music]
e
the peak earthquake would be very good
cause
cani 6
olot take care
my man
charlize theron kuiken
then there is no
good
guaje descals
or twitter
now
haiti guard also
the pixis my mind
capital
no peace what
the aissami
challenge
okay
it's not bad
granma
and once
or
now  not
to them
very
the same
and for which
April it
was 6
to calm down
for more Christian hours
[Applause]
if there is gas gas
repair
and for which
kansas digging
h
nobody
gets off
pretty
with dough
[Applause]
more than him
[Applause] you
pass cable
to four  hours the
bomb lasts
and back
to that ship
he shuts me up he
explains
to restore
for me
like everyone
well
god
nadal
[Music]
spector and
in him
how sad is camagüey